bueno a lo que llegamos el vídeo pasado
es que tenemos 5 pesos libres de riesgo
los cuales salieron de gastar 38 pesos
para comprar una opción de compra y un
bono y obtuvimos 43 pesos de una venta
corta de una acción y describir una
opción de venta así que en este vídeo lo
que vamos a ver es que nos podemos
quedar con estos 5 pesos de ganancia si
cumplimos con todas nuestras
obligaciones entonces pensemos en todos
los posibles escenarios en donde vamos a
variar el precio de la acción subyacente
vamos a suponer primero que el precio de
la acción vale 0 pesos y recuerden que
estamos en la fecha de vencimiento
porque esta fecha es donde hay que tener
cuidado bueno si el precio de acción es
de cero pesos entonces nosotros tenemos
en un principio que la opción de compra
no tiene valor es decir no existe una
razón para la cual tener la opción de
compra por 35 pesos cuando la acción
esté en cero pero bueno no todos son
malas noticias la buena noticia sería
que en este caso tenemos la opción de
cubrir nuestra venta corta recuerdan que
cuando tenemos una venta corta de algo
tú estás pidiendo prestada la acción y
vendiendo la y en el futuro tendrás que
comprar la acción para
cubrir la venta corta comprar la acción
y regresar el préstamo a quien te lo
haya hecho y entonces ahora tenemos pues
cero pesos para vender la acción y
esencialmente regresársela a que nos la
prestó comprar la acción para cubrir
nuestra venta rápida ahora bien otra
mala noticia es que la opción de venta
que escribimos recuerden que nosotros
vendimos la opción de venta es decir
recuerden que nosotros se la dimos a
alguien más para que nos venda esa
opción a 35 pesos y después el precio de
acción va a cero y entonces ellos pueden
comprar esta acción en 0 pesos y
vendernos la a 35 pesos entonces
tendremos que gastar 35 pesos negativos
porque lo estamos gastando para comprar
la acción al titular comprar la acción
al titular pero si lo vemos por el lado
positivo tenemos un bono de un valor de
35 pesos y este bono va a ser el que nos
va a salvar la vida porque lo vamos a
utilizar para poder pagar la acción de
valor de 35 pesos al titular y si se dan
cuenta al final todo se va a cancelar
los 35 menos 35 nos dan 0 y así podemos
conservar nuestra
de 5 pesos seguimos teniendo nuestros 5
pesos de ganancia todavía y bueno eso es
cuando el peso de la acción se va a cero
ahora vamos a ver un segundo caso un
segundo escenario en donde el precio de
la acción se dispara ahí vale 70 pesos
entonces vamos a escribirlo el precio de
la acción sube hasta 70 pesos y lo
primero que quiero que veamos es que la
opción de compra que tenemos recuerden
que la opción de compra es comprar la
acción a 35 pesos por lo tanto la compra
tiene un valor de 35 pesos y tenemos un
bono que también tiene un valor de 35
pesos entonces la opción de compra es de
35 pesos vale 35 pesos y el bono vale 35
pesos la opción de venta está por los
suelos
es decir la opción de venta no tiene
valor pero en este caso ya se cubrió la
venta corta por lo tanto vamos a
escribirlo la opción de compra no tiene
valor y se cubrió en la venta corta
tenemos que comprar también el regreso
de la acción realizar la acción aquí nos
la prestó y ahora cuando regresemos la
acción costará 70 pesos porque ahora
usaremos los 35 pesos de la compra más
de 35 pesos del bono para
nuestra venta corta pero bien si tenemos
70 pesos para comprar la acción y cubrir
la venta corta entonces ya acabamos
porque lo que acabamos de ver es que yo
me tomé un precio bajo y un precio alto
de esta acción y no importa cuál es el
precio de la acción
estamos preparados para cancelar los
pagos para cubrir nuestras obligaciones
y todo esto en la fecha del vencimiento
y además quedarnos con la ganancia de 5
pesos nuestra ganancia el libre de
riesgos en la actualidad esta
posibilidad si existe aunque vale la
pena mencionar que existen personas
capaces de escribir programas de
computadora que encuentran oportunidades
y las explotan de manera muy pero muy
rápida